Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week here at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are continuing our friendship series,
friendship throughout the years
with moving into the middle school year.
So we started last time talking
about elementary school.
Now we're moving on to middle school,
which for us was seventh and eighth grade.
Just a two-year period,
but a very substantial
two-year period in our lives
and in our friendship.
Developmentally, and
yeah, the fact that we're-
Did you get pubes
during that time?
Looking at things...
Oh, that's a teaser.
Sure, I'll weigh in on that one.
I entered with pubes.
Looking.
Just so you know.
Looking at it through.
Came right through the
seventh grade door with pubes.
I'm making a point.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry,
I'm making pube jokes.
Yeah, I really don't wanna talk about...
Okay.
I'll save this for later.
Pubes at this point
That's why I like graciously
said, oh, it's a teaser.
Meaning, we'll talk about that
later and maybe he'll forget.
Oh no, I won't now .
But it seems that you
wanna talk about it now.
I like having this series
because it re-contextualizes
some stories we've already told,
helps us access experiences
maybe we haven't talked about ever,
because we're looking at time periods
we've talked about
before, now middle school,
but through the lens of, well,
what was our friendship like
and how was it developing?
What was the dynamic at
that stage, you know?
So it kinda gets at new
things through that.
So I'm looking forward to it.
It's like therapy without a therapist.
Ah, yeah, I just think that we tend,
as we said with the elementary school,
when you tend to have
this blanket statement
about being best friends and like,
oh, they were always so close
and they always had this
dynamic, but there was...
I mean.
A development.
Yeah, it was an evolution
and everything's changing
in middle school.
And I'm wondering how
our perspectives differ
on how that impacted our
friendship positively
and negatively.
So I wanna get into that.
But we should get into
something else first.
It's been a couple of
weeks since we launched
the new Mythical logo and we
thought this was the best forum
for us to talk to each other, and to you,
about the response that we got
and clarify a couple of things.
So kind of by design,
it's been a few weeks,
it's been three weeks-ish,
or maybe a little bit more,
since a lot of chattering conversation
amongst the Mythical Beasts has happened.
So having kind of this
delayed conversation
is also something we can talk about,
'cause that's the decision we made
that we just didn't
wanna jump into the fray,
but I guess we should set
the stage a little bit.
Well, yeah, I mean, for
those of you who don't know,
we changed the official
Mythical logo a few weeks ago
and the first sort of indication
that that was happening,
I think, is one of the
things that we got wrong.
So the way that it
works if you're a member
the Mythical Society,
is you get a preview
email of what's to come.
Whether that's new merch or whatever,
in this case it was new merch.
So you're the first to know
of any big announcement
in the world of Mythicality.
And so, that-
Mythical society members
are the first to know via this email.
And on GMM on the following Monday,
what we were gonna announce the logo
and announce the new merch
collection with the logo.
So on Friday before a
holiday weekend, essentially,
which is just typical,
if we're gonna announce
something on Monday,
that email usually goes
out the week before.
An email was sent out,
and the thing that was
emphasized in the email,
wasn't just that we
were getting a new logo,
but that if you wanted
to get Randler merch,
Randler being the mascot,
the little mouse with antlers and wings,
it's been a mascot of
Mythicality for a very long time.
If you wanted to get Randler merch,
you needed to act on it right now
because that was going away.
Now-
It may have said forever, I don't know.
No it said.
I hope not.
The implication was that
it was going away forever.
It was an unfortunately worded thing.
Right, so it seemed, it
was an email about merch
that seemed like it was an
announcement about the new logo,
which doesn't have the Randler in it,
being an announcement
that the Randler was going away forever.
Yeah, and so.
And in a livestream.
In the livestream on the society...
We did clarify this the very next week.
Which was on Tuesday of that week,
we did clarify that
Randler is not going away
because that was one of the things
that people were really responding to.
And it was just something that it was,
we're blaming ourselves for
accidentally seeming to imply
that that was happening.
When what we were trying
to say is that that line,
that iteration of the Randler as it exists
as part of the company-wide
logo is going away.
So get it while you can get it
in the same way that we always
say about last chance stuff.
And I think there was a bit
of a marketing spin to it.
Yeah.
That, of course,
we don't write these emails,
we can get into this a little bit later.
But yeah, there was a bit of a
marketing spin that was like,
hey, this is going away, you
emphasize the scarcity of it.
If you want this particular
hoodie with this particular
Randler logo on it, we're
not making it anymore.
But it got conflated with an announcement
about the logo in general.
And it really, the
conversation unfortunately
became about the Randler going away.
Yeah.
And that was never the plan.
So honestly it wasn't even an
adjustment to fan reaction.
It's like, oh my gosh, they
really love the Randler,
so we gotta backtrack and
say, we're not taking it away.
That was never the plan to take it away,
so it wasn't an adjustment.
But we are
taking responsibility
for the communication
that seemed to imply that,
that caused a lot of consternation.
Yeah, so it's a bit unfortunate.
I wanna come back to,
maybe a little bit more
a conversation about why we
decided to change the logo
and what we were thinking and
how we're feeling about that.
But while we're talking
about miscommunication,
I think it's probably a
good time to talk about
a previous tweet that went out
a week and a half before the logo,
or a couple weeks before
the logo was announced.
Yes, and now we're talking
five or six weeks ago, but.
Yeah, I mean, why not, right?
So there was a tweet that went out
that essentially said
something along the lines of;
I mean, if you wanna read it
just so we can get it
exactly right what was said,
and then we can tell you
what we were trying to say
and then again what we,
unfortunately, miscommunicated.
I think the big note here for us-
I don't think we
miscommunicated as much here,
I think it was just left...
Too open to interpretation.
I'm on Twitter, but I'm.
Mythical is art.
I'm searching Twitter on Twitter.
"Dear beasts, we value your enthusiasm
and hearing your feedback
on all things Mythical.
However, lately we've seen a
few of you directing questions,
frustration and even anger
at members of the crew,
both on their personal social accounts
and indirectly on public forums,
which is unfair and not in
the spirit of Mythicality.
Please don't cross those lines
and always use the
appropriate company channels
to raise your concerns and
constructive feedback."
And apparently this wasn't as clear
as we thought it was
when we read it and said,
yeah, this works because...
The way that a lot of
people interpreted this
and it is your right to interpret
it in any way you want to,
but we're going to clarify
what we were trying to say,
to try to clear it up.
The way that a lot of people interpret it,
is as if we were saying
that you cannot criticize
the things that we produce as a company.
As a media company who
puts media out in the world
that we were trying to
police what you say.
Of course not.
I don't, that's never been our intention.
We understand that the whole idea
is when you make
something for an audience,
that audience has an opinion
and that the audience's opinion matters.
And if it's negative, that matters,
and we take that into account.
I kinda think that's wrapped up in,
we value your enthusiasm
and hearing your feedback
on all things Mythical.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is kind of exactly what we said,
'cause I just read it again.
Yeah.
The line that we were talking about
is maybe when it comes to you didn't get,
something customer service related.
Yeah.
Or like,
I have a question about
my merch showing up
or a stipulation about
something else regarding
any of the stuff that we do from a
customer service standpoint.
Yeah, let's be let specific,
we were talking about the
stuff that we sell, the merch.
That's what we were talking about.
People get upset about
getting the wrong size,
not getting something on time.
And being delayed,
And then reaching out to the
members of the Mythical crew,
who that is their job, they
work in that department.
But tracking them down
on their personal socials
or talking about them personally.
Just because you know
that's somebody's job,
that doesn't mean you go to the,
you cross the line to
their personal socials.
I don't even care if they talk
about their work and stuff on that.
It's like everybody talks about
their lives on their social.
That doesn't mean that you can make it a-
It's not a valid place
for customer support.
Well, we have provided.
Feedback or complaints.
We have provided official company avenues
that you can go through
to lodge those complaints
and those complaints get
heard and those complaints
get considered and answered.
Absolutely.
So we wanna, we're sticking
up for the Mythical crew here,
our team, so that they can have
a healthy work-life balance
so that fans aren't coming
into their personal timelines
and in their personal space online and...
And these are specifically people who
aren't public personalities.
Making complaints.
So, there's a distinction
between someone who has a show,
what we would call talent,
for lack of a better word.
I hate that word because it makes it seem
like only people on camera have talent.
But that's just the industry term
for people who have a show.
We're not saying you can't
criticize the shows that we make.
We're just saying that if
somebody works for Mythical
in a non-public capacity,
and then you're reaching out
to them on their socials,
or you're talking about them publicly,
we're standing up for them and saying,
they didn't sign up for that.
And we don't want them to be harassed,
especially because we've
provided avenues and channels
for you to file your complaints.
It's not just harassment, it's even.
Engagement.
Even polite engagement
on your personal side
is crossing a line that
we wanna help preserve
their work-life balance and boundaries.
So when it starts to intrude,
it's like we wanna stand
up for our employees.
And again, there were some things in that,
in the way that it's
worded, I completely get it.
You could think that what we were saying
is that we don't wanna be criticized.
So if you took it that way, we're again,
we're blaming ourselves
for miscommunication.
The thing that we're learning-
I'm not being too hard on ourselves,
but you know, it's always hard
to know how things.
But I am.
I am, okay.
Okay.
So I am being hard on ourselves
because this communication is
incredibly delicate, right?
And also, I think one of
the things that's hitting me
is it is a really cool
thing to have a brand,
to have something that
people care about enough
to have an opinion about.
That's a privileged position.
For people to care
enough to have an opinion
about the decisions that you make
is something that ultimately
that's the positive
that I take away from this is that,
well, if you didn't care,
you wouldn't say anything.
So you do care, and so you
are passionately engaging
and we appreciate that.
Our end of the bargain needs to be
that we communicate things
as clearly as possible,
but it also is a little bit daunting.
And it is the reason that we
did not immediately respond
to all of the comments about that tweet
and all of the comments about the logo
and the lack of the Randler and all that
because 99 times out of 100.
99 times out of 100,
when you try to clarify
and say something else you
end up saying something else
that you didn't mean to say, we're doing,
I'm sure, I am 100,000% sure
that I am saying something
within this 15 minute span
that will be then
misinterpreted by someone else.
It is the nature of communication.
We waited so that all the energy
would die down a little bit,
as opposed to getting
into a back and forth
and trying to clarify, then,
oh, well what about this?
And then you have to clarify,
and it becomes this endless thing.
It's not an easy thing.
So it's just like, we'll
just wait a little bit
and just talk about it naturally,
the way that we've processed it,
but not try to get into
this back and forth
where we're trying to clarify
and just end up digging a bigger
hole than we've already dug
by miscommunicating in
the first place now.
Now, so back to the logo.
Well, first of all, as a
side note about the tweet
about team members and boundaries.
I was feeling bad for Trevor,
'cause all these people were,
it was all this conjecture about,
well Trevor just launched his podcast
and people are being hard on him.
It's like, I'm ecstatic.
And my conversation is with Trevor,
he's off to the races, man.
It's like.
Yeah.
And he's a public persona
that he can take criticism, publicly.
That's the other side of the
boundary, the appropriate side.
But that's not what it was about at all.
It made it seem like we were saying,
we just launched something
and you're not happy with it.
We did not make it seem that way,
but it was open enough to interpretation
that people took in and
ran with it that way.
So it's like, we, I just wish
we would been more specific,
but again, we didn't want,
well, we're being more specific now.
And again, and I think
we haven't really talked
about this that much, but my application,
my lesson learned is
just don't say anything.
Honestly.
My application moving forward,
is that if I go back and do that again,
I would try to speak
directly with the people
who were being singled out on Twitter
and help them develop
tools to deal with it
rather than bring and
making it a public thing,
which just stirs up a bunch of
stuff and misinterpretation.
I don't know, cause I.
It's difficult to know
what to do.
It is, and I think the
other way to look at it is,
it's been confusing,
it hasn't been perfect.
An expectation of perfection
in communication is stupid.
But that is what the expectation is.
Okay.
Today, to clarify.
But we can't live up to that standard.
But I think this process maybe
is helpful for everybody,
'cause I think you would
agree that we're proud
that we took up for our team
members and that we're valuing,
even if we're misinterpreted
or people start to think
the wrong thing about us,
that we don't want criticism,
I'd rather have that
than have our employees
be put in a compromising position.
And that's why we did it.
And having it, so I do think
we made the right decision.
And that's why I retweeted it
because I don't do a lot of Twitter,
but the reason I retweeted
that was just like,
I want those team members
to know that I care
and that I wanna defend them.
Yeah, so I don't wish we didn't do it.
I just think that even though
But I don't wanna make
it worse accidentally.
What we're talking about right now,
I don't think makes it worse.
I do think you can clarify
and make things better,
and I think that's what's happened.
Back to the logo.
And well, would you agree with that?
Because the last thing you said was
if I had to do it over
again, I wouldn't do it.
But I'm counterpointing that.
I agree with the spirit
of what you're saying,
but I don't.
It depends on how people
respond to this conversation?
It's one of those things that I'm just,
I'm not smart enough and I don't think
that anyone at our company is smart enough
to communicate in a way
that will be completely,
perfectly received by everyone.
And so my tendency is just to be like,
just do the things that you
want to do as a company.
Don't explain the decisions,
don't defend the decisions
because it just feels like a lose-lose.
But you know me, I love
to try to explain myself.
I'm trying to learn how
to explain myself less.
Well, and to me, I think
the thing that I value
is an understanding with
the Mythical Beasts.
And if there's confusion, if
we're not on the same page
or if we're misunderstood, or
if we're misunderstanding them
or individuals in the
community, I wanna resolve that.
It is a relationship.
Which again, to come back to the logo,
we're excited about the
logo, we like the new logo.
It's very calculated in a lot of ways.
It was never our intention to,
with taking the Randler out of the logo,
there was a rationale
associated with that,
but it was never our intention
to get rid of the Randler entirely.
It never even crossed our minds.
That was not a conversation we had
that we were eradicating the Randler.
We were just trying to
take the Randler out of
the broadest and most outward
facing expression of Mythical,
which represents us and
everything else that we produce
and everything else
that we're going to produce as a company.
We wanted something that was
broader and less specific
just for the broadest company logo.
And from an outward facing perspective,
your logo communicates not
to everybody on the inside,
it communicates a lot to
the people on the outside
who are being introduced.
And the fact of the matter is,
the Randler in that context
of an outward facing logo,
it was confusing to
people because it sent-
Who've never heard of Mythical.
Who've never heard of Mythical
because it sent this visual cue
that this is a fantasy brand.
This might be a sci-fi
brand, this might be a-
Well, it reinforces the misconception
that we're trying to use the word Mythical
in the traditional sense.
When in reality, for all these years,
we've been trying to
redefine the word Mythical.
Mythical doesn't mean the traditional,
make-believe, Mythical creatures.
Yes, we use that imagery as a fandom
because it just makes sense and it's cool
and Mythical Beasts is cool.
But our content
has zero to do with that!
And so it's really confusing
to people when you're saying
this is who we are, this
is where we stand for.
So this is a change, it's
actually been a long time coming
in terms of thinking about,
we've recognized it
both internally and also
as we've gone through like
brand exploration processes,
we've learned that a lot of people,
when they just see Mythical and they see
this little magical
creature there, they think,
oh, these people must do
some sort of fantasy thing.
And so we're like, okay,
well that's not what we do,
we're a lighthearted brand
but that mascot's important
that mascot.
Well, let me.
I wanna get to the mascot thing,
but just to sit a second
with the squiggly M.
Yeah.
And this new thing.
So we were excited about that
because it would provide clarification.
And I'll go further to clarify,
Mythical is a place that you can come to.
It is where curiosity and comedy create.
Laughter and curiosity.
We can say it that way.
It is where laughter and curiosity
create meaningful community.
Yeah.
That's what Mythical means to us.
Right.
So unfortunately, by making this headline
in this one email about
the Randler going away,
parenthetically, just
within the new merch line,
we confused things and we sent
the absolute backwards message
to some Mythical Beasts
who say, and I fully
acknowledge that the Randler
to many Mythical Beasts,
maybe you, means...
It means that community,
it means that connection.
Coming up with the concept
of the Randler as a logo,
naming it, designing it, designed by a fan
and then redesigned for one of our logo,
for a couple of our logos over the years
and incorporating it into that.
Incorporating it into a lot
of other iconography as well
said, this is a community.
This is something that we're doing
and experiencing together.
And it's very important to all of us.
The Randler is one of many
representations of that.
It's not the only one.
Yeah.
But it is one, and you know what,
we're very sentimental
when it comes to things.
We're still celebrating 10
years of Good Mythical Morning.
Even months later it's like,
and we know that it all hinges
on the strength of our community.
Yeah.
So we fully agree with the
sentiment behind the feelings
of the Randler, but when you take it-
But we can also have a new
logo that doesn't have it in it
and it doesn't mean that community
is not extremely important,
a central part of what we're doing.
The relationship that we
have with Mythical Beasts.
Well, and to be specific.
Is just as important
as it's ever been.
And ironically, taking the
Randler out of the largest,
broadest, company-wide expression,
is intended to be a step
towards inclusivity,
as opposed to you see it
and it's a barrier to entry.
It backfired in the way
we communicated that.
Now, that does not mean that
you have to like the logo.
If you don't like the logo,
you don't like the logo.
I totally get that.
We can kind of explain what
we do like about the logo.
We like the fact that the
M itself in the Mythical
becomes the logo that stands alone,
which that's not something
we ever had before.
We had to use the whole word
or we had to just use the Randler.
Now we can use a part of the word
that actually stands for Mythical.
We like the way it looks,
we think it communicates
that this is like sort of a winding road.
And we're kinda just going at
this by the seat of our pants
and we're on this.
That's definitely
how we always feel.
And we're very on this
very long winding journey.
That whole journey not
the destination thing
is our experience.
Some people have noticed
that there is seemingly a
height difference in the M
that's relative to me and Link-
That's an illusion, it's the same height.
Both bumps.
But that it's backwards.
Well, when we first saw this logo,
we were like, oh, one of
the cool things about this
is it's got like our
height difference in it,
but it's technically backwards
from the way that fans experienced it.
We talked about this.
So we tried it the other way.
Everybody hated the way that it looked.
Including us.
But here's the thing that it
flipped a switch in my mind.
I was like, you know the cool thing
about keeping it this way, is
that this is the perspective
that you would have on
our height difference
if you were standing next to us,
looking in the same direction.
Not us over here and you
over here looking at us,
but if we all get on the
same side of the line,
we all get a line on the same perspective.
When we all start moving
together in the same direction,
the Rhett and Link height difference
would be the way that it is
reflected in the Mythical logo.
To me again, that was another like, aha!
This is actually, if you
really stop and think about it,
even cooler.
Now that may sound like I'm just trying
to justify something, that's a part of it,
but also when I saw it
that way and I was like,
this actually becomes
more meaningful to me
when I'm like, well, I'm embracing it
because I think it looks
better but then when I see
that it has this other
really cool element,
that's just like when
you're reading a poem
and you're coming to
your own interpretation.
Sure.
That's how I'm seeing it now.
I love that.
And for me it's cooler
that way.
I love that.
And it's, yeah, it's
a symbol of community.
Yeah, and we're all together
facing the same way.
And the Randler's not dead,
you don't have to, he's not retired.
He's gonna be around and we're
definitely not ruling out
that he will come back in a new iteration
or on his own shirt or
what, you know, whatever.
It's like, that was never the intention.
So if you love the Randler,
the Randler's not going away.
Randler ain't going
away, he's very special.
But yeah, I don't wanna
keep getting into it,
but like you think about Belvedere
and how that mascot is incorporated
into Good Mythical Morning intros
and how that's changed over the years.
And, you know, if he
went away for an intro,
then he might come back for an intro.
It doesn't, you know, let's
not be so precious about this
that we can't change,
especially when we're excited
about the evolution of the brand.
And we wanted a new logo and we like it.
But there's so many things
that we're continuing to learn
about communication and
having a growing team.
And I'm just being honest,
I'm not trying to throw
anybody under the bus,
I'm actually saying what
we have to learn in this
and the responsibility that
we have to take is that
when you have a team, we got
over 100 people working for us
across Mythical and Smosh, and...
Sometimes there's
sensitivities might get missed,
or you might be looking at
something through a certain lens
of like, okay, I'm marketing
these new line of sweatshirts
and people need to know that
the other ones are going away.
So you kind of turn up the
marketing in the subject line
that we don't see or approve, honestly.
Yeah.
Because we can't, because we
would literally sleep less
than we already do if we were to do that.
Yeah, we can't do that.
And so, it was a mistake
and mistakes are made.
It's not the end of the world.
It's part of the, it's
something that we expect.
And as leaders, I think is
something that we have to learn
that it's part of the
equation, but also say,
what are our lessons learned
here that we can convey,
Hey, you may be newer to the
team and the team's growing,
but this is what the Randler
means to Mythical Beasts.
Yeah.
So there's a level of sensitivity
that we could have communicated.
Yeah, so it's a lesson-
We could have done a better job.
It's a lesson learned for us.
We don't blame anybody
for misinterpreting it,
it was open to misinterpretation.
We don't blame anybody, we
don't have an issue with you
if you have an issue with this decision.
We don't have an issue if you are mad
that the Randler's not a
part of that company logo,
we don't have an issue if
you don't like the new logo.
I will say that we are super
excited about all of that
and our team is super excited about it.
So this is how we're moving forward.
But that doesn't mean
that you have to agree
and we wouldn't expect you to agree,
and it doesn't make you any
less of a Mythical Beast.
Nope.
Because you don't agree.
I mean, that's one of the
things that I see some comments
where people are like,
you're not a Mythical Beast
if you don't agree with them.
Well, no, we're not looking
for everybody to fall in line.
We want you to be genuinely
and generally happy and excited
about the things that we're doing,
but we know that the only people
that we can please all the time, is us,
and it's not even that
easy for us to do that.
But that's the only
barometer that we have,
is our own personal interest and desire,
and our team as well, right?
So that's how we decide
what we're gonna do.
And we usually have a
really good barometer
of how Mythical Beasts are gonna respond
to something.
Yeah, yeah.
But it's a bit of a shake
up that these two things
were misses in terms of our sixth sense
of knowing how they're gonna
respond for different reasons.
But again, it's lessons learned for us
and I'm just super excited about where,
about the future of musically,
I'm, ah, I mean Mythical.
I just get so confused lately.
I don't know.
It's late, yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's very confusing.
So thanks for hearing us out
and thanks for being patient
and for trusting us over
the past three weeks,
if you didn't hear the little announcement
in our livestream on the society.
If this is the first
you're hearing of this,
thanks for trusting us
for the time it's taken
for this to come out.
I think that's something we wanna do,
slow the pacing down here.
No need to be as reactive.
Yeah.
We have an established relationship.
Just because something shakes things up,
I had to resist the
urge, I know you did too,
to like...
Oh yeah.
To like step in at the moment
and let's make a video
right now, let's clarify!
That weekend when we were
seeing all the comments,
trust me, we were together, actually.
When Link got back from
his weekend outta town,
he came straight over
to the creative house
on Presidents' Day when no one
was really supposed to be working.
And we started figuring
out what we were gonna say
in a response video.
And then we stopped because we said,
listen, we don't need
to get, if we do this,
we're in an emotional place right now
and we're gonna end up saying
something that we regret.
And we're gonna say something else
that's gonna be misinterpreted.
So let's just hold,
clarify this one thing on the livestream
and then let's just talk
about it on "Ear Biscuits".
And we're gonna trust the Mythical Beasts,
and then we're going to trust
that they're gonna trust
us in the meantime.
So I think this is more
relationship building
and a little bit of boundary setting too.
Okay, I feel good about it.
Sorry that took all the time that it took.
It was like a, was that
like a business meeting?
It was a mini podcast.
All right.
Okay, we're gonna talk
about middle school Rhett and Link.
But first we wanna just...
I don't know if this.
Oh, why don't you read?
This won't be the...
I wanna promote
Stevie's new podcast, which
we want you to check out.
But let's just go full
ad read on this thing
'cause I like the
description of her podcast.
Every good coming of
age story finds excet-
I'm sorry, brother.
Dang it, man, you messed it up.
Every good coming of age story
finds its setting in high school.
In hallways filled with
lockers and anxiety,
school dances with awkward poses,
first relationships and heartbreaks,
drivers licenses and drama club,
lunchtime clicks and part-time jobs.
There's something unifying about
the high school experience,
whether good or bad, in the
people you spend it with.
For some people, those adolescent friends
become lifelong
companions, but for others,
graduation day marks the end,
and it did mark the end for Stevie
and her high school best
friend Naegheen, until now.
Every week, host Stevie Wynne Levine,
from Good Mythical Morning,
and Naegheen Homaif-
I can't, see, I'm supposed
to be the announcer
and no one told me how to
pronounce her last name.
Okay, thanks for putting
me in this situation.
You're welcome.
Nageen H...
Will unpack universal high
school themes and topics,
recounting their own personal experiences
and individual perspectives
in an effort to rekindle
an old best friendship 15
years after they parted ways
in robes and mortar boards.
What's a mortar board?
I think that's the
graduation cap, brother.
Can they bring their
friendship back to life?
Premiers Friday, March 18th.
Friday, March 18th in
the year 2022, Stevie.
Oh, it's called "Best
Friends Back, Alright!"
I didn't even say the title.
Stevie and Naegheen premier
"Best Friends Back, Alright!"
So it's like one of those
TikTok trends where it's like,
could you be a voiceover artist?
And then you have to like do something.
I completely failed that TikTok trend.
This is not about you,
this is about checking out her show.
I'm excited about it, I
like that dynamic of...
What am I gonna learn
about their friendship?
It's friendship based.
And is it a new friend,
is the friendship gonna work now?
I mean, and is doing a podcast
gonna make it easier or harder?
Well, we'll find out.
I don't know.
All right, "Best Friends Back, Alright!"
Let's get into middle school.
So for us, middle school
was kind of a continuation
of elementary school,
Buies Creek Elementary,
went from kindergarten all
the way through eighth grade,
but there was the middle school hallway.
The whole thing was shaped like a Z.
Well, a very straight Z.
Like steps.
And then you-
What is that? That should be a letter.
Why is that not a letter?
So like the bottom right
It's like an L with a...
of your Z is the...
It's like an H with the,
if you look at a H
and you just grab the top end on the left
and the bottom end on the
right and you tear 'em off.
Yeah.
That should be a letter.
I guess knowing that layout of the school
is not really the thing I wanted to,
that was that important to
No, no, I'm really
interested in this.
spend that much time on it.
But over the years you would move up
the elementary school hallway,
and then you would start
going to the next hallway,
but that was like fifth
grade, maybe sixth grade.
But you weren't considered,
definitely sixth grade,
but you weren't considered
middle school there
until seventh grade.
And the reason is because
that's when your class schedule
changed from one teacher
all day to multiple classes
where you went to three
different teachers.
Yep, and we were in the
same class for all of those.
So we moved around together.
Both years.
All of the...
Yeah, once you were in a class together,
you stayed in that lump.
Yeah.
But you got a locker.
Yeah, you got a locker.
Locker for the first time.
You could play sports
because that was when
you could get on the basketball team.
Before that it was just-
We both played on the soccer team.
Before that we did done recreation soccer,
but this was like school soccer.
Yeah.
School baseball.
School basketball.
So it was kinda cool that
like your whole school career,
you kinda saw this whole trajectory
and you could see the middle schoolers.
You could see those eighth graders
coming into the lunch room and stuff.
So it was like, you really
had something to aspire to
'cause it was right there in front of you.
And it wasn't a huge, scary
deal to go to the middle school
because it was just going
farther down the hall.
It was one of the more easy,
it was the easier transition
that I can think of
for most people having to go to
a new whole new place and new friends.
It's everybody I was in school with before
with the one new person
from Nebraska that shows up.
To me, this is all wrapped
up in the talent show,
which we have talked about before,
but at the end of the year,
it was those three teachers were in charge
of putting the talent show on,
so any student could sign up
for what they wanted to do.
And then there'd be that
assembly during school hours
where everybody would come
in and sit in the auditorium
and the seventh and eighth graders
would perform their talents.
And I had been thinking about this from,
just intently from first grade.
Oh yeah, 'cause it's like,
these are celebrities.
The first time I ever saw.
I was like, what in the world.
In school celebrities
getting up there.
How do I get up there?
Performing a song and
there would always be
this big grand finale, the
biggest act would be at the end.
And you'd go in there and
you'd look forward to it,
and then they would do it again that night
for the parents who would come in,
so you'd have two performances.
So by the time-
I didn't even remember that.
Yeah, by the time we
were in seventh grade-
And we had practiced in sixth grade
because the fall festival,
we did OPP and made it,
are you down with Halloween,
that was sixth grade.
And we talked our way into that.
Yep.
There was not supposed to be a performance
of any kind at that thing.
And we were like, we gotta get
ready for this talent show,
we gotta know what it's
like to be up on the stage
of this auditorium and
perform for a full house.
Yeah, so by the time, as seventh graders,
we formed our posse and
picked out our rap song
that we were gonna perform.
We did, um...
We had a big posse.
We did "Digital Underground", same song,
which had Tupac in it,
and then we added on,
and then our friend Ben Greenwood,
he came out with his drum machine.
Not on, though.
And he didn't turn it on?
No, 'cause we played the track.
That's right.
And we played a second song.
But he had drum machine.
We added a second song onto the end of it,
maybe that was eighth grade.
Seventh grade was huge
because it was our first year doing it,
and they didn't put us last,
but they put us close to last.
And we really showed up the final act.
I don't even remember what
the eighth graders did.
Everybody forgot them.
By the time we were eighth grade,
we knew we were gonna do,
"So What, So What, So What's The Scenario"
by A Tribe Called Quest.
And we had more people in our posse,
but it was a big deal.
And one of the reasons we chose-
That was like a victory lap,
the seventh grade talent show
was the really coming of age.
We chose songs that had different parts,
different rappers in it.
'Cause you can represent,
these people can each be
represented by someone.
And so the "Scenario" had what,
like four, five people rapping in it?
Maybe six.
Man, those were the good old days.
So yeah, just a picture.
Oh gosh.
That's who we were
at the time, we were just
thinking about being on stage
and performing and getting attention.
But also, I was in a place
where my sixth grade year
had ended with my first ever girlfriend.
A one month long relationship with Leslie,
there's a video on YouTube.
'Cause she happens to be
Link's first girlfriend too,
where we called her and reminisced.
Yeah, on the vlog channel.
'Cause yeah, seventh grade.
Yeah, I found out, we were in
different sixth grade classes,
I find out you were dating her.
And then I was like, first of
all, this is how I find out.
You didn't tell me.
That's an indication of sixth grade
being in different classes.
You start going with Leslie and
I didn't know ahead of time.
That's an indicator about...
That was just something
that we didn't talk about.
Maybe we weren't that close.
Maybe it was just something
you don't talk about.
No, I was only talking
to the people that I felt
were necessary to pull it off,
which was her best friend, Amber,
who then became my
girlfriend in eighth grade.
Right.
But talking to you about it
wouldn't have caused it to happen
so there was no reason to
consult with you about it.
Unless we were like really
good friends, Rhett.
I didn't talk to anybody other than Tate.
I talked to Tate, because Tate
was also interested in her.
Oh you were still trying to box him out.
I did box him out.
By telling him, "Dude,
I'm going for Leslie."
Well, no, I think I said
something like, "May the best man win,
but just so you know,
I'm also interested."
I'm sure you didn't say,
"May the best man win."
But my mentality, now, first of all,
that relationship lasted one month.
There was no hanky-panky,
there was nothing,
not even a holding, there
was a holding of a hand
at one dance, that was it.
No kissing.
I wanted to, I didn't have the nerve.
But I'm bringing the
possibility of what it's like
to have finally been in a relationship,
and I already made it very clear
that from very early on I was girl crazy.
But the thing that I had
was the girl craziness
without any game whatsoever.
I had no idea how to talk to girls.
My go-to move was just staring
and waiting to see if they stare back.
Like I was so not good and it's like,
thing is that I was actually
a pretty sociable person
and I was, oh, I wanted to
get up in front of the school,
and I wanted to give a
speech in front of class.
I wasn't awkward in those settings,
but when it came to women,
I just didn't know how to proceed at all.
I just had this really
high level of desire
and then no game at all.
But that did give you an edge
because I think a lot of
kids were still like me.
I was very timid and I was like frozen.
But you weren't frozen, you took action.
Yeah, but my actions were
sort of characterized
by timidity in one sense though.
Like I don't know what I'm supposed to do,
I'm gonna talk to the friend.
I did not talk to friends, I did not.
You didn't do anything.
I didn't do anything,
so I'll give you credit for that.
I mean, I was having a
conversation with Amber
in history class and
she kept talking to me
about the boy she liked.
That happened to be you.
And I kept trying to guess
who it was, and I was
guessing all these people.
And then I think I probably
guessed everybody except me
until I realized it was me,
and then we started going together.
Right.
It was never that easy
for me, just so you know.
If it had to have been
that easy made for me-
It was so easy, yet, I made it
so difficult.
If I had to had the desire
that I had, but then the level of interest
from girls that you had, you know what?
I would be the father of a
lot of children right now
or something would, it would be bad.
You know what I'm saying?
That's not necessarily
bad, having a lot of kids?
A full quiver?
I mean, okay, yeah, you're right,
Proverbs does say something like that.
But so in seventh grade,
me and Amber started going together.
That's when I had my first
kiss at the Lillington,
Ruritan club.
Ruritan building
for somebody's birthday.
But who were you, so seventh grade?
Seventh grade was a dry spell for me.
You weren't even
at that party.
I was primed and ready
and pubed up and everything.
Shit.
Just, I was, lemme say there was-
Primed and ready and pubed up.
There were things happening.
The plumbing was working and
the plumbing was working often.
I mean, I tested it constantly.
Great, great.
I was so ready,
so ready.
Great.
You weren't even testing your plumbing
at that time, were you?
No.
Golly, so much missed opportunity.
No, well, I mean one tends to catch up.
You won't ever catch up with me.
I mean, you could...
You'd have to...
I'd have to die!
You'd have to quit your job.
Wow.
You'd have to quit your job
to catch up with me.
What do you do for a living?
I'm just masturbating all the time
to try to catch up with Rhett.
You know what, I'm not gonna do that.
I don't advise it.
I've slowed down quite a bit.
I don't want it to fall off.
Well, no, it's like lifting weights, man.
It's like a bicep, yeah.
The more you use it.
Is it though?
Well, definitely, if you don't wanna go-
That's your rationale all these years.
Your justification.
If you don't have a semi-regular release,
now, first of all, nocturnal
emissions will kind of
take care of it in one sense,
but it's actually bad
for your prostate health
to hold it in, man, you gotta let it flow.
I let it flow.
Yeah, I know you let it flow.
Thank you.
I'm talking if you're like,
oh, you're not currently in
a relationship and you don't,
I'm just saying, let it
flow, keep the hose going.
Keep it going.
Okay.
But I mean, you got a
girlfriend in eighth grade?
Amber .
Yeah, the same one you
had in seventh grade.
That's right.
Yeah, and that's when I started dating.
So we are using first names now, huh?
'Cause we've talked about
these relationships so much
the names already out there, Anna.
We got whole songs about this.
Oh, wait, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Anna became my eighth grade girlfriend
and I'm proud of her,
she's was always smart,
and I think now she's as smart as ever.
She's the smartest of all of us.
Some sort of a lawyer
situation.
I think she's at Harvard.
Yeah, she's very smart.
I mean, which is
indicated by her long term
relationship with me.
It never made sense to me.
But she was also very sweet.
So that's who we were at the time.
You were coming around a little bit.
I was thinking about girls nonstop,
but our friendship was
reaching a new level
because a couple of things:
Number one, we were-
Especially when you
weren't dating anybody.
We were-
So I think seventh grade
was an acceleration for us.
Yeah, number one,
we were in all the same classes together,
which isn't something that
had happened consistently,
'cause it was like every other year
we'd be in the same class
as we established on the last podcast.
But another thing that was happening,
jumping off of what we
talked about last time,
is our level of sort of
enthusiasm and seriousness
about our faith was taking off.
To kinda, just a little story
to put this into perspective.
I don't think I've ever talked,
maybe I've talked about
this but around that time,
and I think it was the summer
between my seventh and eighth grade year,
I suddenly became obsessed
with whether or not I was actually saved.
This is a very common thing
in like evangelical circles,
especially Baptist circles,
where, because you hear
things from adults,
like if you're not completely
sure that you're saved
and you're lost, you're saying
these really damaging things
to kids about their certainty.
You're making their
eternal salvation be based
on a one time event that
they had to get just right.
And I had prayed the Sinner's
Prayer and done the whole,
I want Jesus in my heart
and forgive me of my sins
when I was like five years old.
So for a lot of times
in the back of my mind,
I was like, did I really understand it?
And I remember being at a
Christian concert, NewSong,
who came to the D. Rich
Auditorium at Campbell University
where we saw many concerts,
also saw a hypnotist one time, and I also
heavy-petted my girlfriend
in the balcony of this same place,
just to put things in context.
But not in the same
night that you were dedicated.
Not the same night.
I was not at this NewSong concert.
Oh boy, you missed a
show, you missed a show.
My mom actually was-
Five white guys with
goatees singing in harmony?
Yeah, and they're still around.
NewSong is this, they're like Menudo,
they just replace the members.
Oh, well, it's gotta stay new.
So you went for a rededication?
No I didn't, again, I've always been,
I'm more timid than you might think, okay?
I'm more timid than you might think.
It takes a lot of,
you gotta check your pride to go forward.
Well, the thing is, is that what happened
was they were like, raise
your hand and come forward.
It's a classic invitation
where at the end of a concert,
you haven't really done the concert
if you don't invite everybody
to make a personal decision
for Jesus right then and there.
And I've got this overwhelming
feeling that now is the time,
I gotta just make sure, I
gotta make sure that I'm saved.
I couldn't go forward because I was like,
I knew so many people
there and I was like,
I don't wanna confuse them.
What are they gonna think about me?
So on the way home with
my parents in the car
is when I said, I started
crying and I was like,
I don't think, I don't know if I'm saved
and I really wanted to go forward.
Well, this is like seventh grade?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn, you're like crying in the car?
Yeah.
'Cause maybe we talked about it,
but I don't think we talked about it.
You might have said I rededicated my life.
Before that night, I remember that summer
'cause I think that that concert was,
it was either the beginning of seventh
or beginning of eighth grade,
I can't remember the exact.
I just remember that
summer, I couldn't go,
and this is where I have
sympathy with people
who have obsessive compulsive disorder
and get obsessed about
one particular thing
that maybe they think they
got wrong or they need.
Having this thing that
I kept going back to
that the moment that
my mind would move off
of whatever I was directly engaged in;
playing a video game,
shooting a basketball,
boom, I would be hit with this.
Oh man, I might die and go to hell
and I've gotta get this right.
Wow.
And it was overwhelming.
It was really, again,
I know I don't have obsessive
compulsive disorder,
but it was this one time where I was like,
now that I've grown up and I understand,
I know people like my wife who have it,
it's like, oh man.
But for you there was a buildup to it,
and did that NewSong night give
you the relief you desired?
Yeah, I never thought about it again.
Sealed the deal.
'Cause then I was like, I
don't know when I got saved,
if it was five or 14.
And then as I got older,
I began to understand more about grace
and understand that like it's,
do you think God was sitting,
and if I was that worried about it,
it means I was probably saved.
Now, of course, I don't believe
any of that framework anymore.
But at the time I very much believed it,
and it was the most important thing.
Well, it does go to show you, I mean yeah.
In our involvement at church
and in the youth group
and in the choir, they were Sunday morning
for Sunday school and church,
Wednesday night was youth night,
Thursday night was like the choir night.
It's like, we were still
involved in all these things,
and Tim was our youth pastor.
He was bubbling over
with joy for all this.
He was like a super
sweet, nice, sincere guy.
He was enthusiastically
in love with Jesus.
And enthusiastically,
all-systems-go on evangelism.
And between him and Benny
Endsor who was involved,
he was our choir director back then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like middle school.
Right.
And you know, we were like,
so this is after "The Bible
Tells Me So Show" stuff,
which basically, update on that,
we have the-
You found it.
We have the church play digitized
and we're gonna find the right time for us
to do like a participant commentary.
We didn't direct it, on
the Mythical Society,
'cause I think with the
rights that's the best,
maybe the only, place we can do it.
So we'll let you know when that happens.
Do you think you're gonna get sued
by "The Bible Tells Me So Show" people?
Boy, they are.
You think they're still doing that show?
They're very litigious?
Yeah, they might be, I don't know.
So this was the age of,
by the time you get in
seventh and eighth grade,
you can start to go on
mission trips, baby!
Oh yeah.
That was huge for us
because not only were we,
all the stuff that we
had been doing at church
and like how tight-knit
our group of friends was
that had come up through
all of the indoctrination.
Now we were going out, we're
taking trips in the summer
and you didn't wanna feel too
guilty about that last day
where it felt like a vacation
because we were going
there for the Lord's work.
After all, it's called a mission trip.
You're on a mission to
bring the love of Jesus
and salvation to the
people of the mountains
of North Carolina or the
mountains of West Virginia or
Trinidad.
That's an island.
I've never been out of the
continental United States,
and here I am in-
That was the
first time, yeah.
I think that was after
our eighth grade year.
But all of these mission trips were like,
especially Trinidad,
these are like big moments
of all of us taking this
huge risk where it's like,
what is Tim gonna ask us to do?
He's gonna ask us to like-
He was throwing accelerant
on the spark of your faith, right?
The honest perspective on this,
and every youth pastor knows this,
is that these mission trips are not really
about the work that you're doing,
and they're not really about the people
that you're reaching
'cause most of the time
you're just talking to
people who already know.
And sure, I mean, yes,
there was a little boy
who I used a bracelet to bring to
a personal saving knowledge
of Jesus Christ in Trinidad.
You used a bracelet?
Like you bribed, you said,
"I'll give you this bracelet
if you accept Jesus."
No, no, no, no,
we had the bracelet with the beads on it
and each bead represented
a point in the gospel.
Do you remember what was,
the first bead was black, for sin.
The second bead was
red for blood of Jesus.
The next bead was white
for Jesus cleanses your sins.
Pretty racist, by the way.
And then there's-
Black before sin,
white after sin, but you know,
we didn't pick up on that.
We were also talking to kids in Trinidad.
I think there was a-
But still worked!
I think there was a green one for growth?
Yeah, there was a blue one for baptism.
Because blue is baptism.
That was after the white
was, 'cause you get saved
and then you make a decision for Jesus.
You make a public decision with baptism
and then green, you grow.
I think there was a yellow at some point.
I think yellow was the rededication.
The inevitable rededication.
The point I'm making is
that it's really about
the way it solidifies and
accelerates your own faith.
It's those milestones that
if you want your youth group
to like suddenly be on fire,
you go somewhere together
and you basically have
a trauma bond experience
together and then you're all in!
Yeah, you're going on
this trip to like this
Christian camps do
foreign island.
the same thing.
But Christian camp is, you're
not doing as much ministry.
This was all, it was all outward oriented
so like you were put in these
like outta your comfort zone.
Every day you would go and
let's paint this woman's house.
And I have a scar on
my knee where I stepped
through a barbed wire
fence and like ripped out
a chunk of my knee.
I always remember that
trip to the mountains
of North Carolina, painting
that woman's house.
And I remember some of us was like,
we gotta go up to the
door and talk to her,
like, we gotta make sure
that she knows Jesus.
And just kind of having this
sense of mission and obligation
and you know, you're serving people,
but you're also trying to seal the deal.
And yeah, you either had a bracelet
or you would be taught to,
you could use the five
fingers on your hand.
Yeah, that's cool.
So it's like, put your
thumb up, thumbs up.
Good news.
I've got good news.
Point your index finger.
You are gonna die!
You're going to hell.
And then middle finger.
I guess middle finger would be
going to hell.
Going to hell.
I think you it's like, so I don't know,
those first two are like,
you're going to hell.
See? Bird.
Yeah, right.
And the ring finger's you gotta
make a commitment to Jesus.
And then the pinky is
like, you got a little,
now your faith begins to grow.
It's a little faith.
That's probably not what it is.
It's basically taking
people down the Romans road.
But you see these tools that we were given
that then we had to put into practice
and every night we would come back
and we'd have these-
Gospel in a hand is what we called it.
Circles where we would do popcorn prayer.
We would share our experiences
and pray for one another.
And I was a seventh grader.
It was very meaningful because we didn't,
there wasn't a lot that we
had to care about that deeply.
Again, I think that's one of the reasons-
Taking huge risks with your friends.
That's why religion is so effective
is that there is this
deep longing for meaning.
I mean, I'm sitting there
just whacking off every day
and thinking is this all there is?
It's just whacking off?
I mean, it's okay, it's pretty cool.
But you're feeling horrible about it.
I was feeling horrible.
I wasn't feeling as horrible about it
as I would in high school,
it got worse and worse.
But what I'm getting at, is I was like,
there's something lasting
and there's something deeper
and more meaningful, and
there's something eternal
that I can be a part of.
The work that we're doing is eternal.
And we were, you and I,
there was a group of friends,
but like there were more girls than guys
in our youth group.
Holly, Holly was a part
of all these trips.
Well, you're making a point
that there were older girls,
there were high school girls
and a few guys on these trips too.
But that was the other thing,
is that you're sitting there praying for,
and hearing this high school girl pray
and maybe she'll pray for me
or maybe I can pray for her.
It was intimate.
It was like, it was awesome.
But you and I were the most
committed of our friend group,
and we were like the only guys
who were as committed as we were.
So it very much resonated with us
and became even more of a
center point of our friendship.
Right, to bring it back to us,
the way that we were
connecting with each other.
And I think this is
when a certain dynamic,
from my perspective, this is
a dynamic that was developing.
And I wanna hear what
you think about this.
Okay.
My parents were together,
still are together,
and my dad, the way I saw
my dad was that he had...
He had the knowledge
about everything, right?
You wanna know what to
think about politics,
you wanna know what to
think about religion,
he's got it figured out.
And he was smart, but he
was also very assertive
in how he talked about it.
Yeah.
And confident.
And so I would sort of take
the things that he said,
and yes, the things that
our youth pastor said,
but it's just, you really
wanna know what's the real deal
you gotta talk to my dad.
And then I would sort of assimilate that
into the Rhett version, which whatever.
And then I would be like, well,
I've gotta get Link
straightened out about,
he's gotta know what to
think about politics.
'Cause that relates to
your faith and the role
and what God is trying to do
through politics in the world.
And this is what you need to
think about predestination.
This is what you need
to think about Baptism.
I've got this information,
now I've gotta give it to you
because well, you don't have a dad at home
who's telling you these things.
Now, this was not a calculated thing
and I never thought about it that way,
but that dynamic existed.
Like I was getting this information
and I had a willing recipient
of that information in you.
Oh yeah, I mean, we did
talk about beliefs a lot
and yes, whatever the dinner
table conversation was
at your house about politics or religion,
we would talk about the
next day and I would just,
I'd be like, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like, just, you know,
I was just looking for youth pastor
and I guess your dad through you
to just tell me what to believe,
give me the right answers.
I'll ace this test, you
know, this feels good.
So yeah, that was my predisposition.
And neither one of us-
So to kinda lock in.
Neither one of us had a
contrarian or questioning
aspect to our personality.
Now, I kinda developed that
over time, I mean, obviously,
by deconstructing and there's
a little bit of that in me
that came out.
But at the time it was-
That wasn't until late
college and afterwards.
There were kids who
were already being like,
well, hold up now, really?
This is what y'all,
this is what we believe?
We were just primed for,
this is what we believe.
Yes, how do I believe
it really, really hard?
How do I align my life
completely with it in every way?
It was like, this is the
most important thing.
Never crossed my mind
that it might not be true.
Yeah.
It was just like,
this is it, man.
And by you, what I was getting from you
if I would bring something like that was,
oh, he's just as serious
about this as I am.
And so we began to separate a little bit,
especially from our guy friends.
Right.
As these guys who we would,
we took this seriously.
We began to bond more aggressively
because of the way that we were separating
and kind of gravitating
towards this view of our faith.
Yeah, and seventh grade was the last year
that Ben was in school
before he went to homeschool.
I think.
That was another big factor.
He was easing out into homeschool
because of his chronic fatigue syndrome,
and so by eighth grade he
was basically not there.
He didn't go to church with
us, but we would still,
he still participated in
the talent show with us.
We'd still go to his house
and like do dance routines
and learn like rap songs and stuff.
So, I mean, y'all were still very tight.
But the amount of time-
It was this point where we
became more of a threesome
Well, I would say,
Friendship.
I think we were more
of a threesome earlier,
and then I think this is when,
with Ben's chronic fatigue,
there were days when I
would call over there
and Ms. Greenwood would answer
the phone and she'd be like,
"Ben can't do anything right now."
Yeah.
And as a seventh grader,
especially me, I just was not,
I've never been, I'm
still having problems...
Right.
Talking to people.
Which we've already talked about that.
So that ended up being this thing where,
okay, I'm not spending this time with Ben,
I'm not doing this thing.
Every day during the summer
between fifth grade and sixth grade,
I was gonna be at Ben's
house doing something
and you would be there a lot.
But the default was,
we're going to Keith
Hills to do something.
And that was changing.
Now it became, this is when
in the "Book of Mythicality",
we're talking about you and I
Riding the bikes.
riding our bikes,
and meeting at the midpoint
at the middle of town.
Yeah.
And I had enough confidence
as a seventh grader
to start riding my bike everywhere
and spending the night
at your house more often.
And that's when we would start
doing the flashlight wars
and we would go to the Keith Hills gate.
I would come along for the
things that you'd been doing
for years with your neighborhood friends.
Setting off fireworks at the gate
and having the security guards show up,
or like the campus police
for Campbell University.
And they would get on
the loud speaker and say,
"Boys, we know you're
in the woods, come out."
I loved it.
And then I would start
to come out and realize I
was the only one walking out
and then I wouldn't walk out.
And then we would sprint
back to your house,
and I was so much slower that
me and your neighbor, Heather,
weren't fast enough to keep up,
and we got caught in the
headlights of the security car.
And then we had to go talk
to the security guard.
But he gave us a really
strong lecture and let us go
'cause you ditched us!
Yeah, man, I mean, every man for himself.
So yeah, I was kinda
getting in the mix there
and having more sleepovers,
and starting to gain confidence.
And none of that was
registering with me by the way.
Things didn't register, I
don't think things registered.
Things registered with me in terms of,
'cause I remember basketball
was the another thing where,
I mean, we were definitely
best friends by this point.
And church was the engine
and then school was
just icing on the cake.
But like you were on the
basketball team as a seventh grader
and eighth grader, of course.
I find it wild that we
did play soccer together.
That's something that I tend to forget,
I wanna come back to the basketball,
but like you were the goalie, right?
Yeah, much to my, I did not like it.
They're like, you're so big.
'Cause you were so tall.
I was like, man, I should be
up there scoring goals, man.
And I played, I liked soccer.
I was pretty good at it, at defense.
You know, I couldn't run a lot,
I didn't have a lot of stamina,
hence the security guard thing.
But I could play some good defense.
Yeah, 'cause sports were becoming
a really big part of my life.
And, of course, I was
gonna play everything
that we were allowed to play,
which those were the three sports,
soccer, baseball and basketball.
And I was just hanging
on by the soccer thread.
Other than that-
And again, I didn't know that you,
'cause we didn't talk about these things.
Now, as a parent of teenage boys,
I get the fact that you're just not,
there's a whole part of your brain
that you're not really using
and you really look back on
these things reflectively.
But I'm thinking of things
like, he's playing basketball,
and he practices basketball so much,
this really infringes on
us being able to hang out.
I believe, I'm pretty positive,
that the reason why I
started keeping score
for the girls basketball team
was because it gave me something
to do that I was attached,
I traveled with the basketball
team with the boys and girls.
So I could-
You get to go on a bus.
I got to go on the bus
and I could keep score for the girls
and then just watch the boys game.
'Cause I thought it was cooler
to be able to watch the boys game.
Versus keep up with it.
Yeah.
Pandora though, she was
tough to keep up with.
She was tough to keep up with
as I recall.
She was a stat machine.
Yeah, just a layup tyrant.
But that was part of my equation.
It's like, I wanna be in the mix, I wanna,
what's my middle school identity?
I'm okay with being the
scorekeeper if I can be on the bus,
if I can be in the mix.
And you were, so you were
processing things on that level?
I remember that, yeah.
Yeah, to me-
But I also knew that I
would never talk about it
'cause it's like talking
about your feelings
and being needy is just
a real sign of weakness.
Like what am I supposed to say?
It's like, well, do you
think I can be a scorekeeper
so that we can spend time together?
But just to clarify, our
kids talk about that stuff.
It is very much a generational
and also a geographical thing.
There was probably kids in certain places
in the world that were,
and in our community that just wasn't
how you process life as a kid.
Right.
So for me, it was just like,
oh, there's a sport, I can play it.
I can be good at it, okay.
It never crossed my mind do I want?
Am I having fun?
It wasn't about having
fun, it was about winning.
It never crossed my mind.
It was just, you have to be as good
as you possibly can at this.
And of course you have to be as good
as you possibly can at this,
and you have to be as good
as you possibly can at this.
And it wasn't just sports.
It was, oh, you also have to be
as good as you possibly can at academics.
You have to be as good as you possibly can
at the talent show, at giving
a speech for the class.
But it didn't feel like pressure.
It just felt like a way of being.
Yeah, this is the plan.
I mean, and it was such
a tight-knit community.
In our middle school classes,
seventh and eighth grade,
we had the same three teachers;
Ms. Wakus, Ms. McClam and Mr. Royal,
who was also the basketball
coach, PE coach, health teacher.
Our group of friends, whenever
something would happen
or there'd be like strife,
there will be drama with the girls
and sometimes it would
involve guys and dating,
and sometimes it would be
us doing like stupid stuff.
But regardless of what happened,
that there was drama or trouble,
all three teachers would
take it upon themselves
to hold a tribunal to resolve it.
They wouldn't send anybody
to the principal's office.
They were sparing him 'cause
he had the rest of the school
and I think that they liked to be
more heavy-handed than he was.
You remember, you'd be in
one class and all of a sudden
a knock on the door and another teacher
would call the teacher
out and then we just,
we'll be back in a minute student.
And then instead of coming
back in, she would say,
"Rhett, Link, can you
step out into the hall?"
And then we'd step out into the hall,
and all three teachers would
be there laying into us,
questioning us about something we did.
And sometimes it would
be like calling the girls
out into the hall and
there'd be like six girls
out in the hall with the three teachers
just trying to have a,
it's a tribunal, they were put on trial.
And it was kind of amazing!
I remember this in general.
I don't remember it as
specifically as you do.
I knew I remember when
the six girls would go,
okay, well I know why
these are the six girls
who are going out because
they had a sleepover,
but that one girl wasn't invited
and now her feelings are hurt.
So that level of drama,
that middle school drama.
The teachers were, one of 'em was a parent
of one of our friends.
Right, one of the girls
in the group, yeah.
But they were all like very involved.
I never thought about that being
one of the dynamics.
It was like street justice.
Yeah.
I don't remember
what the punishments were?
We never really got much of a-
It wasn't really punishments
as much as it was the
tribunal and the lecture
was the punishment.
You know?
Yeah.
'Cause we never got suspended.
No, because everything we were doing,
we were all really, we all
made really good grades.
And we were good kids,
We were good students.
but we were mischievous.
Yeah, which we definitely
carried on in high school.
But that middle school drama thing,
they were, it's just so fascinating
that they were so in the weeds,
and we were scared of 'em.
And that's when I was told,
when you get to high school next year,
they're gonna stuff you in a locker.
Well, as it relates to me and you,
I mean, I'm surprised that
that didn't happen, but as
it relates to me and you,
Never happened.
I think that middle school
is when people began
to think of us as a duo.
Yeah.
Right?
The teachers.
Yep.
That's why if you got
called into something,
I would get called and vice versa.
Our friends, it's like, oh,
Rhett and Link, they're a duo.
And again, this was not
like an intentional thing,
but it was like, oh,
there's a school dance,
there's the lip sync contest.
It was like, oh, well we're gonna do
DJ Jazzy Jeff & The Fresh Prince
because they're the ultimate
duo, we're the ultimate duo.
We started performing together,
we started seeing ourselves as a team.
If we could work together on a project,
if there was a way to be like,
hey, we're gonna do this Oedipus video.
That's right and we used
Anna's video camera and we did
our first video project.
And it was like
we were kind of thinking
about it in that way,
and then we did a whole different one
over at Heather's house.
Yeah.
The next year.
There was a cornfield and a scarecrow.
Yeah.
But we just naturally fell
into this creative partnership.
That's right.
That really hadn't happened
up until that point, right?
It happened through the talent shows,
through video projects,
that was when we began to
work together creatively.
And I think that, now
we had done things like
the stupid little radio shows
and stuff at the house, right?
Yeah, the pause tapes.
But what I found and, of
course, I'm going around,
I'm sampling every friendship.
You know what I was doing,
I was going to every single house,
I was spending the night
at everybody's house.
And I had in mind, not an agenda,
but I sort of just naturally
carried with me an agenda
without thinking about it.
It was just my personality.
To what?
I wanna have fun in a particular way.
Okay.
I am interested
in having fun in this way.
Okay, now we've got this radio.
I think that we should do this radio show
and we should do characters,
we should do voices and that kinda thing.
There was no one else who
was receptive to that,
besides you.
I was all in.
You know what I'm saying?
No one was receptive
to that way of thinking
about amusing themselves.
Ben was! Ben was.
Well, as we discussed, Ben
was even more of an ideas guy.
Yeah, right.
And he was more out there.
I mean, again, when you go over
to his house and he's like,
"Let me show you the new
dance that I invented",
and it's kinda
like "Riverdance".
I mean, he was a wild
card, he was amazing.
But yeah, I was very much like, yes!
I had a sense of...
Yeah, we're gonna hang out,
we're gonna make stuff,
we're gonna do stuff.
This is it, this is it, this is amazing.
And regardless of what it was-
This is precursor to the blood oath thing.
I definitely had that sense
at that point.
If we're gonna hang out
for an afternoon,
whether it was me and you
or Ben was there or not, it might be like,
all right, we're not
just getting together,
we're getting together
and today's mission is,
fill in the blank.
Go out and cut down a tree.
Try to make a raft that we're gonna float
in the backyard.
Take some stuff off of this tree
and to make a tea that
Ben said we should make,
because we found it in
a book in the library.
Yeah.
We had missions, we had agendas.
Go into that sewer!
Right, it carried with
it a sense of mission.
And then that was,
we filled our time with
that way of thinking,
and then we also filmed
any creative endeavor
with the same sense of mission.
Like this is gonna be
good and this has gotta be
the best thing that we've ever done.
Again, we never talked about it.
There was no, let's have a
meeting and figure this out.
It was in a natural thing where,
and then with Ben sort of checking out
because of the health
problems that he was having.
I mean, I still believe to this day
that if Ben had not had those issues,
the three of us would've grown up
and started something together.
Yeah, I believe that.
Something creative together.
But what ended up happening-
It was a sense of identity.
The two of us were kinda left.
And then people started
to group us together.
That's when people would say,
it would be Rhett and Link,
Rhett and Link this, that, and the other.
A lot of weekends we would hang out,
we'd spend the night at one
person's house or the other,
I think it started to happen
a whole lot at this phase.
And so, it was this identity
of, oh, these guys are a duo.
Yeah, I definitely think that
people thought of it that way.
Yeah.
And there's another dynamic
that started to develop at this point.
That I think is a dynamic
that has characterized
a lot of our friendship since that point.
And we wrote this into "The
Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
in the way that we
described the Rex character
talking to the leaf
character about something,
about the film school thing.
And I remember, the
first time I can remember
that this happened was it
was between eighth grade
and ninth grade, so we
graduated from eighth grade
and we were getting ready
to go to high school.
We were swimming in the
river like we did so often,
and so often that summer
it was just me and you
swimming in the river, no Ben.
Right.
I was casting vision.
Right?
For high school.
This is what high school's
gonna be, get ready.
And I was doing it through
the lens of the women
that we were going to get to meet
because now it wasn't just all the girls
that we've known for eight years.
It was the girls from Lillington
and the girls from Anger.
The girls that we've seen
And the girls from Lafayette.
when you played 'em in basketball.
The cheerleaders.
You saw the cheerleaders
and you saw the girls in the stands
and you saw, and hey, I met
a few score-keeping girls
Right.
from other schools.
Smarty pants with glasses on.
Now-
Good with a pencil.
And so, I remember sort of
trying to cast this vision,
and again, that was when it kind of began.
And then I feel like, I kinda
carried this role forward.
Oh yeah.
To be like,
I remember the specifics.
here's the vision
and this is the way you
should be thinking about it.
This is how you should be
getting excited about it.
And again, you were this
incredibly receptive person
that responded in a way
that no one else would respond to me.
Yeah.
No one else would listen
to me in the same way.
Yeah, and I was like, I
didn't just soak it up,
I did give it back.
It was this like, okay.
You were on board.
You were like, you know
that cheerleader from Anger,
Melissa, like, oh man, she's-
Yeah, she's at the top of the pyramid.
She's, yeah.
Mm-hm.
And then, I remember we
were talking about her,
I remember two other girls
we were talking about, specifically.
They were both in relationships.
That didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
I said those would not
last over the summer.
Right.
I was right.
Melissa stayed in a relationship,
that did not pan out for me.
Well-
'Cause your vision, I think my vision too,
was that I was gonna date her.
We had two girls that we
were gonna date together.
Yeah.
Mine didn't work just because
she wasn't receptive to me,
because I couldn't convince everyone
of everything at all times.
Right.
Once they saw my face ,
they'd be like, okay, well
you better be something,
there better be some
other things going on.
Stephanie's a smart girl.
Yeah, right.
We've already said
these names, so it might
as well go on record.
But yeah, I do think that
that's when it really,
when it really started to come together.
You talk about the
accelerant of a mission trip,
and we just took that
mentality into our friendship.
Like we totally got each other
and we were going in the same direction.
We wanted the same things,
a lot of it being attention.
And I was scared as hell of girls,
but every day I was getting
more ready to overcome that.
It would take until 10th grade to do so,
but we can talk about that next time.
'Cause I think this is
a good place to stop.
The next time we pick up this series,
of course, we'll be in high school,
and that's an interesting
phase because our friendship,
our friend group grew a lot.
And then the things that we
were devoting our time to,
you no longer played soccer and
I didn't have anything to do
with keeping score for basketball.
There was more, I'll say
threats to our closeness
in a lot of ways.
But then there were some key
things that counteracted that.
So we can walk through all that
and see what we can remember
next time we pick this up in,
I don't know, in a month and a half.
We'll keep going at
like that cadence, but-
Okay.
Yeah, middle school was big for us, man.
So I mean, I think that
the thing that I had not,
the thing I wanna remember is
the thing that I had forgotten
until talking about it, which
I think that middle school
is the beginning of the duo.
Yeah.
That was the beginning of
us being seen as a duo.
Right.
That other people
would have perceived us in that way.
And specifically creative,
not just a friend duo but a creative duo.
That middle school is formative.
Yeah.
All right, what's your rec?
My rec is a rec that you recommended to me
that I finally watched over the weekend.
Oh?
"Chillin' Island".
HBO Max is, they got some good stuff.
So when I see something on HBO Max,
I might give that a shot,
especially if it's featuring
Lil Yachty or Young Thug.
And I started with,
because you told me to,
I started with the Lil Yachty episode,
which is what I'm gonna recommend to you.
I don't even know what
the first episode is,
and I don't know, and I didn't
go back and watch it yet.
Did you watch the Lil Tecca episode?
I watched Lil Yachty, then Lil Tecca,
and I was like, I felt bad for Lil Tecca.
Yes.
But Lil Yachty is, listen,
I don't know anything about Lil Yachty.
I do.
Other than what I've seen
That's enough.
in this one episode.
Oh, yeah.
And it's like, what an incredible dude!
I love him.
I've met him at
The Game Awards show.
At that video game awards.
But we gotta have him on the show.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I mean talk about a dude
who just embraces his weird.
Yeah, he's great.
I mean,
he's living on his own plane.
But the show is so-
Interesting, right?
They're just not trying
to do any, they're trying to do something
that is innovative and...
There's three hosts.
It's like a mixed media thing
because there's a narrative
that is unfolding that usually has
a make-believe element to it, right?
Like the Lil Yachty
episode is sort of centered
around the Yeti, the Sasquatch.
But then, what they're
doing is unscripted.
What they're talking about is unscripted,
and I don't know who these guys are.
Do you know who the hosts are?
What's their background, who they are?
I think they're like podcast guys,
they're like hip-hop community.
They're in that mix.
But either they're radio or podcast guys.
I just found myself thinking,
man, I really think I want us
to be on an episode of this.
And then I was just like,
if we go through the trouble
of reaching out, they wouldn't
even let us on because
We're not cool enough?
we're just too square.
We're too square.
You know, they'd be like, what those dudes
from that show on YouTube?
But I just, I want them to
know that we're weird too.
And we like being weird as
much as we possibly can,
it's just sometimes we are
constrained and can't be.
But HBO Max is a place.
So you got a really
self conscious
watching this thing
HBO Max is a place
where you could, I
would just love the fact
that they were talking
about the kinds of stuff
that we talk about when
we're with our friends,
and the conversations go to these places,
these super philosophical
and ridiculous places
where we just all end up making
ourselves laugh a whole lot.
But sometimes it feels like
it's a prank on the guest
'cause Lil Yachty or whoever it is,
they're clearly unprepared
for what's about to happen,
and everybody else kind
of knows the itinerary.
And I think Lil Yachty and Lil Tecca
represent two different
ways to approach it.
But here's the thing,
Lil Tecca's 19 years old.
It's a whole lot to ask, and
also, to go on a fishing boat?
Oh god.
Which I think they were
next to Catalina is
probably where they were.
Yeah, they didn't say.
It's not very
narratively cohesive.
Deep sea fishing,
deep sea fishing is really
difficult to do and he got sick,
and I was like, I
would've gotten sick too.
But the Lil Yachty,
just because he's older
and he's a little bit more
comfortable in his own skin.
Yeah, that's why I wanted you watch
those two back-to-back,
'cause once you appreciate Lil Yachty,
then you really understand how much
out on a limb they're going
with what they did to Lil Tecca.
Oh, and then the guy from
Vampire Weekend shows up.
Yeah.
I just didn't pay attention for a moment.
And then I was like, who is this guy?
Yeah, Ezra Koenig.
And then once he started
trying to explain his one song,
I was like, oh that's the
dude from Vampire Weekend?
Yes.
He showed up?
It's pretty funny.
It's the kinda thing
that we would envision.
I watched it, I did one of
those things where I watch it
and I was self-conscious about two things.
One, how I wanted to be on the show,
and two, how I wanna
make a show like that.
But then, depending on who
you're trying to make a show for,
they will tell you that
this is too weird for us.
I love what HBO's doing
because they're just willing
to just make something that, first of all,
this isn't going to appeal to many of,
many of you are gonna watch this show,
you'd be like, why did he recommend this?
But some of you will be
like, this is my jam.
And so this is for those
who will make that decision
and feel that way.
Yeah, all right,
#EarBiscuits, let us know,
I don't know, what stood out to you
from our middle school tales.
And I know we're gonna be talking
about the first part of this as well.
So we'll get into that
too on some #EarBiscuits.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.